this is oh God
I'm not gonna guess I don't know it's
Bart Ryan
me I don't know Nick dude it's Nick what
[Music]
welcome to an extremely important
episode of careful boys today we have
for this Mysterio oh wow
[Applause]
sounds like a teacher Miss Jill sounds
like a uh
this is Miss G I could tell you your
future it's like the Montebello Miss
Cleo
this Geo Miss Geo Miss Gio Montebello so
uh you weren't here last time we did
this but we did do a Lifeline to you
while we were doing this oh you received
the call so I thought it'd be good to do
it while you're here we're gonna do
round two of JK doppelganger oh great
okay starting with this
this just says didn't know you guys
opened the London office
JK news
out guys and we're gonna go ahead and
judge some of these for ourselves first
up is non-binary Steve Green yes yeah
that is pretty Peter penny green that's
a non the eyes I think it's in the eyes
it's hard for me to to look at uh Steve
Green as a smaller person you know
because he's such a large individual wow
it's just hard for me to see him you
just call him fat exactly well he's 6'4
isn't he that's tall not large bro I
think that's I think it's
interchangeable no I wouldn't have
called them I would call them tall yeah
is large offensive a little bit don't
ever call me large if I said if I said
Steve was wide that'd be oh that's
really bad but a large person unless he
was actually built wide then I'd be like
that's well he's also not a skinny guy
Dan you are flirting with danger dude
you're struggling the line partner Steve
you're fat dude
you're a fatty that's what I meant the
whole time that makes sense they forced
me to say it that makes him really sad I
don't think Steve's fat
you said it I said he's large he's a
large person oh no you know what's a
large person Bart's a large person she
is he likes it though he wishes I'm a
middleweight he's kind of white Bar's
kind of mom he's wider than Steve I
didn't expect you to have so much to say
Mark's got a fat ass yeah he's got a
white ass dude non-binary seed gets a
yes yes now this is oh
Indian Ryan
is that guy Malaysian he's a straight
Indian oh Indian yeah that's an easy one
though that's that
that's kind of Ryan dude kind of Ryan
kind of Ryan but I've never seen the
other guy looks more like I've never
seen you wear your shirt like that yeah
who is it Ryan in an alternate universe
who is this guy I think they're just
making people with dark hair and a beard
that one doesn't really oh Sesame Street
introduces First Filipino American
Muppet that'll look like nobody I
couldn't tell if it says Ryan on says I
couldn't tell that guy supposed to be me
or the Muppet that looks like Kumar like
Harold and cool I think that is him
maybe it is me cow pen all right oh okay
that one doesn't say anything but um
that's that's supposed to be Ryan that
looks like Nick yeah you just look like
everyone I used to look like everyone
Indian and and yeah can you do it Metro
Indians that's Bart
that's bird what does that say 50 off
laser hair removal
you'd be the perfect what's Bart doing
in this Oz Laser Clinic ad what are you
doing in there part you got a nice smile
man that is that does that's David so
dude that is David So this says
26 million views you won't be there for
me that's like Bart and David combined
he's got the David
that's Mike's song what do you mean
that's Mike's song Joe combined that's
tactical Mike's song
that's so pretty so funny that's Mike's
song into Airsoft who's that that's bar
same one Anthony is that supposed to be
Anthony
the nose throws me off oh oh I kind of
because bird doesn't have a round nose
like that Bart has a pointy nose oh
that's that's Steve I think this one
this one is about the middle girl oh bro
oh Geo
what it says so Geo isn't Stella Middle
from flow yeah I guess not have you ever
have you ever gotten yeah
I'm just going through my powers of
deduction in this room all right just
throwing it out there
Nick [__] Nick
just so you know there's no David's in
here oh no no you shouldn't have said
that then it has to be Joe no it's fat
Nick that's me and Joe's love child
this says Bart after finding out yakult
uses bacteria from a healthy Americans
Feast oh my God holy [__] that don't
look like bark that's racist that's what
that is look it looks like Joe Moore I
do like food
dude that guy's face is drawn on for
sure that's Anthony
is Anthony I wish supposed to be yeah I
don't know these aren't really are we
bad at this game is that supposed to be
when did that
deductive reasoning again I don't want
to use that oh Ryan buff I don't know
you do you know this guy I know him
do you think he looks like me in person
no but if it had to be anyone buff Ryan
yeah Ryan buff all right uh
Steve was Russian if Dolph Lundgren had
a [__] brother
I thought Bart's head was square that
was super Square whoa what the [__] oh
that has to be Steve if Steve was a
magician it says it says yup man man
like Steve if Steve was a magician or a
Christian rock singer dude that's Jared
feather Jared feathers
yeah the hair
he just looks like Steve's little
brother or something
not quite Steve Steve
[Laughter]
oh [__] that's a good one
that's a moon phase for sure
hey can I show you something young
Jackie Chan yeah yeah I gotta show you
this
my Uncle that's Jackie Chan yeah my
dad's brother looks just like Jackie
Chan right no you look just like my
buddy put me in the old app filter and
this is what it looked like
and who's that what you're saying that
looks just like Jackie Chan bro why did
you say your uncle well because my uncle
I look like I thought you were gonna
show me something about yourself
you know you look like it was a really
weird setup he looks like David hingwali
here
he's like you guys would never believe
what my uncle looks like here's me but I
we all look like Jackie Chan as the boy
yeah it was a weird setup you guys got
the Chinese eyes but that looks like you
right now right now yep that does look
like you smell like that
you also sit back like that you also
relax like this smile like this
yeah look at those Chinese eyes that is
what you do dude yeah that's me dude you
look like a porcelain doll Anthony
for sure
it's just this okay he's cute and the
eyebrows I'm not saying anything I don't
look like a four nine Steve who's in the
EDM do you see yourself at all in this I
do in this context I can is it the beard
the face too it's also a bushy eyebrows
bro I've seen Anthony make that face it
says happy birthday Chef Anthony did Ken
send that imagine necklaces and the
whole look at that even his style dude
oh yeah he could be your little friend I
don't wear necklaces he could be a
little brother
oh that guy I like that guy he makes
dope knives he makes the same fish this
guy makes some of the sickest knives out
there yeah that's what Joe doesn't give
a [__] what you're talking about just
straight up says Joe
everyone tags me in his comments that's
that's old Steve that is old Steve it
says Steve's Christmas card to Anthony
that guy's name is Anthony Lee I think
it is yeah wow what a kawinky dink
Beginning to Look a Lot Like Christmas
wow that's old Steve I can't alternate
you kind of looks like George Clooney
that's no that's old it just looks like
that looks like old Steve I think it's
the that's him look at his crypto
portfolio in the future
his hairline and his head shape it's the
easy to draw lips
can't get it wrong easy to draw lips
what's that dude right there I don't
know that's Jimmy's name
I guess if I had to pick it'd be Anthony
but it doesn't really look like Anthony
doesn't is this another Asian guy I need
to look alike I couldn't get a better
picture in fear of police being called
on me oh take it easy bro that's not
even close to Anthony I know but like if
I had to pick what they were saying sure
is it because of the hair yeah it might
be yeah because of the older yeah okay
sure
Barton Nick yeah your love child
what's Juvederm no I can't I don't know
we're not focusing on it bro this guy's
got good skin I think I got a t-shirt
like that you do it says Nick making it
big on Juvederm dude Nick I already made
it Nick got a sponsorship I think he's
making I think so I think I could be
like like small thrills his eyes are
closing though smile normal
hahaha
yeah it's pretty good are you able to
smile when someone commands you smile
smile
when they command me I have my head
starts you look like a pug like when
you're doing like super rare shoots do a
smile that's all upper teeth like him
yeah
I did
you suck at [__] smiling he I don't
even know how he did the lower teeth
only
you can't do it huh I could do a mean
underbite I can do that
oh that's mean yeah
from here down Bart
Bart yeah like here you mean that's Ryan
right there
Steve's singing and on the keyboard oh
great description I really like these
descriptions
this is oh God
I'm not gonna guess I don't know it's
Bart Ryan
that's Nick what fart how the last time
they gave her they showed black Bart
that was really Barbed that's the one
that we call Geo on yeah
not at all no it's just that it's the no
it's the head shape that's why you don't
even see a slight Essence
it's just a head shape no nothing not
even a little bit Yeah does it feel like
looking in a mirror no I got a black
time more yeah the black guy more for
sure you know that guy responded really
he's actual influencer he has 100
something thousand followers what did he
say he said no I don't think we look
alike he's not even close or something
yeah nice I thought it looked like black
Bart
do you think it was he was offended
Steve for sure that's why he's not here
today he's at work
that's freaking Steve dude it's him
roasting somebody that really looks like
him that looks like Steve laughs in that
reaction too yeah he's wheezing with the
hat yeah the matching hat to shirt helps
too which one bro oh God oh my gosh dude
this far left this one's really good are
they the same none of them look like us
oh
Nick Anthony Bart and Joe this one's
more Joe for sure yeah
far right it kind of looks like Joe
though
me because they're Japanese
the Bartlett what the [__] is oozer eats
oozer
doesn't that look like David though the
BART it looks more it resembles more
David look at that loser eat man some
Japanese food delivery that does that
does look like David a little bit more
yeah the guy in the middle I don't know
who that is bro
it's obviously me I don't think that
looks
not even because of the like wavy bangs
well yeah why does why does guys and
girls clothes look so funny I mean I get
it
I get it I guess I don't get it yeah
again no no they just this might be the
worst one she's she's pretty though
whatever this is yeah she looks nothing
like Geo there's not a specific thing
inside yeah this is Geo no way that
could be because I'm here and you guys
are like going back and forth no they
just picked the Latin lady yeah if she's
Latin America she looks like she's our
median or something your argument went
out the window real fast well I mean
she in Glendale what's up
I don't know Bart Steve yeah
what's his name the actor was it uh the
saber tooth yeah what's his name leaf
leaves yeah that's right Donovan bro
damn so if they're white no matter what
but that doesn't even look like Steve
Steve that's a lot of like just random
the outline of his head might be like
Steve but that's about it maybe the nose
he's right behind him dude Joe Mexican
Joe that's so funny Mexican show I kind
of saw it yeah what is it I see this
more than I see the Geo one yeah yeah
yeah okay it's the head shape Anthony
Josh it says
oh wait it doesn't say anything oh you
just duped us this doesn't say anything
it says Luna so it's all of us
that could be Anthony I think this might
have this was supposed to be you whoa
look at the ears move the ear stick out
so like if we put like white powder all
over his face yeah he does look good
that's me Joe and Nick all together
yeah that's a combo dude missing I know
it sucks that this guy's missing but
maybe we're bringing awareness to it
that's Darian
I don't know who that is Anthony Anthony
I do see it more Anthony that's more soy
tip ah yeah that is Filipino Anthony
a little ding huh yep little Ding-A-Ling
that's candy that's can Dude That's
supposed to be me but like [__] back
in the day no that's 10.
it's just the hair that Joe that's Joe
that's Joe back in the day that has to
be a Tanger Joe tattoo
you did for a joke yeah yeah bar shaved
my top head you said you're getting sick
of your ponytail huh I might do that
yeah I don't know I said you really
gonna rock this for a while I don't want
to do that I don't think it's just a
little I'll do a bowl cut like if Ken
and Joe had a baby oh yeah I see that
that's true oh yeah
all right Steve is that Steve no that's
really
like that's Steve if he ran Spartan
races or something that's one of the
best teams that is the best one okay
we'll pack Steve that's Steve that's
Steve once he gives up his monster
he's he's a friend yeah
he's he's shown up a few times everyone
keeps saying this looks like chubby Joe
we did a video together he goes you guys
look like brother what's this guy's name
uh well his name is Chef kale
um Chef Khaled yeah
oh my good [__] that's crazy it's
definitely gel on the right Joe and
Asian James Brown
[Laughter]
that's amazing oh [__]
Nick
dude no it's Asian James Brown dude Bart
and Joe World War II Barton Joe
aim station James Brown is way better
that is good I think he's good
I'm feeling good I feel good though
is that the last one wait let me see
that is funny dude
is really good
Steve has a lot to choose from huh Steve
seems to be like the he's like the
easiest because people just be sending
if it's white it's right all the time I
think a lot of them do it's kind of
resemble they resemble him but then
there's ones that look just like him and
some that are like nah they're just his
fat they look like his relatives that
he's the last one
what do you guys think that any of those
really Brown James Brown was spot on
that's the most accurate and then that's
the one that's about it the best one
ever of all time is Bart in the
Taiwanese uh 7-Eleven oh yeah that's a
hard one at the top to bottom Behavior
the one that was freaking out where the
squat when he's like screaming the khaki
shorts yeah yeah yeah that's that's
unhanded Bart I have shorts exactly like
that no I've seen weirdo shorts your
butt's definitely bigger and nicer I'll
say that but nicer I'll say that but I
don't think he's fat you guys are
twisting my words I think he's a large
man that was a pretty strong he's a
large person dude that's a very strong
opener yeah Steve's at least like 210
bro wow that's [__] up imagine 210 on
top of you bro that's a lot of weight
whoa
no what do you mean like when you when
you get a person who's 210 pounds on top
of you that's
foreign